He sucked Buzz Cut's blood
and he's about to turn into a hemophile.
Once he reaches that stage,
no one can stop him.
Looks like I'll have to use the Heaven
Lily Clan's ultimate tour-de-force,
the Blossoming of the White Lily
in order to defeat him.
What are you waiting for? Unleash it now.
But I need your assistance
to activate this technique.
Don't be so coy.
It's not like we're going to kiss.
Do we really have to...
Yes.
The Heaven Lily Clan banned romance
in order for us to perfect
this exceptional skill.
Kissing someone of the opposite sex can
-activate my bodily--
-It doesn't have to be me, right?
-DaChun can do it.
-But I...
Ichiro can do it.
I already have a girlfriend.
And she won't approve of this.
Dai Bo can do it.
But I'm just a chicken.
I can do it!
Kiss me--
He's too weak.
Chairman Jiang, I'm seriously suspecting
that you're captivated by my...
That looks horrifying.
-You were indeed captivated by me.
-Maybe we didn't kiss long enough.
Want to try again?
I think I've had enough.
What was the order that I gave you?
"Kill him, and bring back his sword."
Then why is he still alive?
Because he saved me.
So I owed him one.
Let me repay it for you
and then kill him.
Chairman Jiang beautified herself.
Don't get so excited
when you're seriously injured.